all right what's going on guys this is
rob and uh i have a theory here
outside of just some observations there
really isn't a whole lot to like back
this up but i do want to know what you
all think about it for no other reason
the fact that you guys do what you
always do which is just shoot down my
theories but uh
let's talk about
c'thon endor mamu potentially mephisto
nightmare let's talk about these demonic
beings
that likely exist in the mcu well that's
not the most accurate statement we know
dormammu exists in the mcu
because we saw him and we know catholic
exists in the mcu because wong
referenced him right remember like in
doctor strange two in the temple scene
right wong was like you know cathode the
first demon to ever practice dark magic
basically constructed this temple so
here's the thing right we know from
doctor strange one that dormammu is a
multiversal entity right like there's
only one dora mamu seemingly across the
whole multiverse that seemed to be the
implication there there was nothing to
indicate that dormammu existed in every
universe because the way that it was
explained by the ancient one and then
seemingly the way it unfolded with
stephen strange is that dormammu
inhabits his own universe right the dark
dimension is in and of itself its own
reality and then
honestly
i think the splinter realms exist
in the mcu and just as as a haphazard
guess with no factual evidence to
support this i think the marvel
cinematic universe is going to kill off
the idea of the negative zone and
they're going to replace it with what is
basically the demonic dimension is
essentially what it is right the dark
dimension and all that stuff now the
dark dimension may very well be its own
thing the negative zone is its own place
the dark dimension is its own place
however there are huge differences here
so in marvel comics every universe has
its own dark dimension it has its own
version of dormammu in fact in the
ultimate universe which is what most of
the mcu is based off of dormammu
literally killed doctor strange the
first time they fought
it was hilarious it was the funniest
thing but at the same time in marvel
comics what you also have is the
negative zone now for those of you guys
who don't know what that is there's a
lot of stuff that goes into it like it's
an anti-matter universe and so on and so
forth the important thing for this video
is that there's only one negative zone
and every universe can access it in fact
depending on how long you're in the
negative zone you can encounter other
versions of yourself from across the
multiverse who may also be exploring it
as well but the negative zone is
colossal and it has its own denizens
right annihilus and all those guys and
that kind of a thing uh and so maybe
that's what they're doing with the the
dark dimension now again they could be
just expanding the dark dimension out to
where it's only one universe among the
entirety of the multiverse but here's
the reason why i say i think this is
happening right why it's kind of a big
deal here a lot of it just goes back to
how things ended with doctor strange too
that what we ended up seeing really in
over the course of the movie and dealing
with the dark hold is that wong had
largely talked about the dark hole
basically being a copy that in essence
cathode had constructed the temple that
existed in wondergore mountain and then
basically put all of his information
involving dark magic into the temple and
then that temple was or at least the
writings were essentially copied and
they were put inside the dark hole now
by one way or another that ended up
spreading across the multiverse so there
ended up being one dark hole in every
single universe now i would say that
this is largely marvel kind of
restructuring the origin of cathode to a
degree we've talked about this before
the origin of catholic marvel comics is
that he was an elder god that in essence
when the earth first came into existence
that the sentience of life on earth
basically right its biosphere uh ended
up spawning a whole bunch of elder gods
they all descended into
madness more or less just became evil
sort of practicing dark magic and
cathode was one of the only ones left
this basically led to the creation of
the demiurge also known as a tomb who
essentially destroyed all the different
elder gods and those who weren't killed
fled to their own individual realms
catholic being one of those he basically
fled to what's called the flickering
realm this basically led to a two
merging into the sun and then becoming
amen ra who basically sired all the
egyptian gods as we know them bast and
you know khanshu and so on and so forth
kind of a neat way to tie all those
things in together with what we've seen
in the mcu so far right now here's one
of the things that could be going on
assuming almond raw and all that stuff
from moon knight is just this own thing
that exists out there and has no tie or
involvement with cathode or anything
like that which is possible but also not
possible what we could say here what we
could really surmise is that if c'thon
really was a being that somehow found
its way to what we would call earth 616
or the main marvel cinematic universe
wreaked havoc for a time it's entirely
possible here the very first sorcerer
supreme basically watum ended up
battling uh cathone and then banished
cathone to his own realm and then in
turn what was left of catholic was
essentially just the writings that were
there that were made available and
before his defeat or whatever it is that
catholic transcribed those writings into
the darkhold and then sent them out into
the multiverse the reason being because
much like in marvel comics cathone is
always looking for a way back into the
main marvel universe itself and those
individuals who start wading into the
waters of the dark hole having no idea
what they're doing can provide a vector
for that to happen the other part of
this is that cathode was basically just
waiting on the scarlet witch he was
waiting on wanda and then in turn he
could use wanda as a vector to re-enter
the realm that's entirely possible here
but the reason why i think this matters
and the reason why it's so cool is
because as you guys remember from doctor
strange too when the temple of catholic
was destroyed all the dark holes across
the multiverse were destroyed as well
they were all eliminated and seemingly
what happened here and this is kind of
the crazy thing this is one of the
reasons why i kind of speculated in the
last video that we did when we were
talking about the incursions why the
dark hole is seemingly tied to it is
because when that dark hold in
basically evil strange right when his
when that dark hole was destroyed his
reality basically seemed to return to
normal or at least started to go back to
being to normal and stop disintegrating
that seemed to be the case i don't know
if that's true you know i don't know
that's definitively the case been a few
days since i watched the movie a little
bit murky on the details there but the
fact remains that this is entirely
possible that what's going on here is
that essentially dormammu and like
cathone mephisto if he exists nightmare
who most likely exists they exist inside
the dark dimension and the splinter
realms are all effectively a part of
that so those of you guys who aren't
really familiar with that again we had
explained this before as well that
basically the dark dimension is not just
a giant landmass by which dormammu rules
everything it's not like that instead
what it is is this the dark dimension
with dormammu basically controlling a
huge section of it but within that
you've also got smaller dimensions right
smaller little places so think of it
akin to how like asgard is a dimension
that you can access in the marvel
cinematic universe but you have to have
the bifrost to do it it's it's pretty
much the same way imagine earth is the
dark dimension and asgard is the realm
of cathode right you can't just go there
right you can't just like get on a ship
and fly there that you actually kind of
have to access it through like
dimensional means but the important
thing here is that it's likely inside
the greater dark dimension the other
part of this is that it could just be
one of these things where like dormammu
rules over everybody right cathone and
mephisto and nightmare and all those
guys he's like the big dog on the block
and they're all just kind of existing
there in the sense that like he's the
emperor and they're all just like
governors more or less right i mean it's
a very terrible analogy in relation to
the kind of people that we're talking
about here you know governor catholic
you know peter parker iii but
nonetheless you know it's just it's one
of those things i think it'd be cool i
think it'd be a great way to take what
is or could potentially be this really
really complex and convoluted concept
and narrow it down now another way to
really look at this and this really
seems to be indicated by clea because
when the portal opened at the very end
of the movie in the post-credits scene
that it looked like the dark dimension
on the other side which makes sense
because clea is basically the niece of
dormammu the daughter of his sister umar
and she's ridiculously powerful and was
at one point the ruler of the dark
dimension after duramamu's defeat and
when she beat umar and so because of
that it's possible that like dormammu is
basically representative of all of them
and that's one of the things that we
also talked about as well that there is
no mephisto that there is no nightmare
or anything like that that is all
basically dormammu but what we saw in
the movie seems to contradict that that
cathode definitively exists now we
haven't seen him yet but he's been
referenced and i would have to believe
that wong would know the difference
between catholic and dormammu and would
know if they were different or the same
beings
i have to believe that's the case but
i'm curious what you guys think about
this right do you think it's entirely
possible here that what's going on is
that the realm of catholic and the realm
of dormammu and all those guys are all
basically in the same place or do you
think that it's just one of those things
where it's kind of off doing its own
thing right that it'd be kind of weird
to say that like catholic rules his own
his own universe and that dormammu rules
his own universe but it could just be a
more expanded version of what exists in
the comics that instead of catholic
existing in the flickering realms that
literally the flickering realms are an
entire universe unto itself and that's
one of the things to know about the
multiverse of marvel comics not all
universes are equal that some universes
are smaller than others and other
universes are bigger than others for
example the negative zone is several
times larger than the main marvel
cinematic universe other universes are a
little bit smaller so it really just
kind of varies so it's entirely possible
that like dormammu rules his own quote
unquote universe or realm which exists
out there kind of independent of any
other universe in the multiverse but
it's not the size of a traditional
universe it's smaller right so you know
it's it's a starter home essentially you
know what it would be but unless you
know let me know what you guys think
about that i'm very very curious to see
what your all stance is because i feel
like this is a very real possibility i
mean we know he exists the big question
is where is he right maybe it's just one
of those things where his spirit just
inhabits the tomb and he doesn't exist
in the universe anywhere right i mean at
that point we're just it's he was
literally just waiting on wanda right
his spirit is quite literally just
sitting in wonder mountain waiting to be
freed by some poor sap who ends up
coming along accessing the dark hold
happens to be the scarlet witch and it's
just the perfect means by which you can
come back
i don't know right i mean that would
kind of seem to be the case that wanda
accessing really being the only one to
be able to use chaos magic in the way
that she can that she's the perfect host
for cathone that's one thing to know
right i mean there's a lot of elements
for marvel comics that are being
borrowed from here a lot of you guys may
look at that and you may say okay but
like if wanda's the scarlet witch and
doctor strange two showed us that in
effect wanda always becomes a scarlet
witch maybe not necessarily the evil
scarlet witch but like she essentially
always gains powers as evidenced by the
alternate reality version of herself
that was possessed because remember at
the end of the movie when she was stuck
out there where the book of the vashanti
was when it was destroyed that alternate
reality version of her like when
possession was over she looked up like
what in the hell and then just flew back
right to her reality so it's not like
wanda only has powers in the earth 616
marvel cinematic universe she's got her
powers across every universe and for
those of you guys who are looking for an
explanation of that that's just the
concept of the phoenix that's all that
is right it's literally the marvel
cinematic universe borrowing the notion
of the phoenix force modifying it and
then applying it to wanda in the sense
that the phoenix force is an omniversal
entity there's only one phoenix across
the entirety of the multiverse and even
though there are essentially an infinite
number of jean grey's the jean grey from
the main marvel universe in the comics
is the perfect host of the phoenix it's
why only she was able to attain the
white phoenix of the crown position as
opposed to any other version of jean
grey across the multiverse so it's
really one of those things in marvel
comics worse like that particular gene
is more powerful or more in tune with
the phoenix force than any other version
and maybe that's what's going on with
wanda right that version of wanda in the
earth 616 marvel cinematic universe is
the most powerful version of wanda
across the multiverse or she's the one
that's the most in tune to be a host for
cathode whatever the case is right it's
one of those things they borrow from
comics you gotta roll with it until we
end up getting some other explanation
beyond that but it's a cool little
tidbit there right i mean there's a lot
of possibilities with cathode so here's
what i want right give me your wildest
theories about cathode in the mcu right
let me know what you guys think because
i'm i'm really excited for this guy's
appearance you know he's gonna show up
somewhere along the line likely in
doctor strange three but let me know
what you guys think with that being said
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace